I don't give much importance to these things
so it's enough to have too
little give me the beer this tastes a bit of
smoked theme it seems like a lot
inside but very light it does not like the surface
and the alcohol content there is a bit of
nothing
there is also  but everything is so one after
the other lighter than war and still it
seemed so sparkling water it is not
bitter it does not smell or dirty water city
bringing you ice in the beer
the half of medicine I am not an expert
in beer but an aftertaste of onion  it's
a little bitter so I like it more
yes it's true the first one was heavier
I hate excuses I don't know how it is always
piss with American coffee with a
sprinkle of sparkling cold nesquik cappuccino
in short I love it and
very good
who is
this  it may be good to remove the
taste of the one before this is more
sparkling but feel more sparkling yes in my opinion this one
is already given here we are more
alcoholic than the others a little more for
one of those bill and katie cradle
exact since  now i did not find the one that
thrilled me but go change from
maybe i transfer to this that they are
beer belly various health do
everything hidden no this is good
after all sbn this beautiful house but a
mixture of my own lemons
the initial impact was  really
terrible but it's not too bad
if i had to do a world championship
of all i would like my dad
fisc you know that in germany the beer is
good
belgium you think i really like this b i
already knew guinness
from that decisive moment never leave
it again i hate  login